this is a prize-winning himalayan rabbit
and it will help us see that an
organism's traits aren't only the
results of which genes they have but
also which environmental factors the
organism is exposed to so we're going to
look at a specific gene in the himalayan
rabbit known as the c
gene
and the c gene encodes a protein which
acts as an enzyme in the eventual
production of pigment and we can see
where that enzyme is more active at the
nose
on the feet on the ears right over here
and then you can also see that it is
inactive
across the body and in some parts of the
head right over here
now the question is what's causing it to
be inactive or active
well it turns out that the enzyme that
the c gene codes for is optimally active
at
15
degrees celsius to 25 degrees celsius
and this alone can actually explain the
difference in pigmentation how does that
make sense well imagine that this rabbit
over here was raised at 20 degrees
celsius
the body itself it's a mammal it's warm
blooded it's going to be producing heat
so the body this area right over here is
going to be
warm
and so over here we're going to be
greater than let's say 35 degrees
celsius where the enzyme that the c gene
codes for is inactive this is where it's
optimally active and above 35 degrees
celsius it's actually not active at all
and once again why is it so warm over
here it's not just the ambient
temperature it's a combination of the
ambient temperature plus the heat from
the rabbit itself
now if you go at some of the further off
parts of the rabbit's body and this is
actually true of our bodies as well if
you go to the ears you go to the nose
you go to the feet
you have less body warmth and so it is
going to be cooler
in these parts of the body and it could
be cool enough so that the protein
encoded by the c gene is actually active
and so you see something very simple can
create this very neat and i would have
to say cute pattern as well
now some of you might be wondering well
could i then based on temperature raise
a completely white himalayan rabbit and
the answer is yes if you had a twin of
this rabbit and you raised it in an
environment that would say
hotter than 30 degrees celsius well then
all of its body would probably be of a
temperature where the protein encoded by
the c gene is not too active or not
active at all and it would be a white
rabbit and people have performed this
experiment over a hundred years ago and
they saw that exact result
and temperature is just one of many
factors there's research where they were
able to make a cyclops fish a fish with
one eye based on chemicals in where it
was reared
there's experiments with light that
depending on the light or the lack of
light at the caterpillar stage it can
affect what the butterfly looks like
when it develops wings
food can activate or inactivate certain
genes not just in other animals but even
in our own bodies there's research
around fasting and how that might
activate or inactivate certain genes
stress can affect genes hormones can
affect genes so the big takeaway here is
an organism's traits are not just due to
which genes the organism has but are
influenced by environmental factors as
well